why don't I started off with Brent's
year of swinging because that was a big
story that was the biggest story I think
a year don't you yeah when I think about
it I think about surely not believing
Brent and then Brent proving he was
telling the truth
well it was on everything what didn't he
prove listen a lot of a lot of stuff
that went down went down when none of us
were there to validate or cover any of
that's how it's just throw that out
there well that's what happens with us
that's the stuff that we were sent on
didn't necessarily end that way the
biggest stab story of the year Robin all
right Brent swinging with his beautiful
wife Kaitlyn it's so steamy I remember
Kaitlyn got her new titties well
remember there were a lot of false start
to the swinging because Kaitlyn was
always injured with her teddy she had
titty injuries there's no false starts
everybody gets into it the same way he
went to the swinging parties soft
swinging first right and Kaitlyn her
titties were still soft and yeah
now they settled very nicely well anyway
this is where Brent just to recap the
year Brent revealed that he was into
soft swinging so you were making out
with his girl yep and you're looking at
your wife yes oh that's weird
yeah it's pretty high Brent weird when
you really think about Brent you
wouldn't be in the same room by the way
he's it fair to say that brendan is wife
are the world's least successful
swingers early we've been married two
years yeah yeah you know all of this has
been going on no it hasn't this is this
is kind of a recent thing do you ever
wish you could turn back the clock and
never have swung no oh my god do you
ever wish oh my god because it's
seriously like you seemed a year ago to
be a much happier person to be around in
the office and to know you actually seem
much more depressed and have a lot more
anxiety I don't know this doesn't seem
to have been a good year for you that's
my
perception of it if anyone disagrees but
that well I mean I agree with Jason a -
it doesn't have anything Ronnie -
swinging Ronnie tell him what you think
he's like a turtle now he sounds a
turtle it's like his head goes into a
shell when he walks around here
he's like dead you feel a darkness yeah
like he's not here half the time
Ronnie's talking about him the way
people talk about someone who went to a
battle
yes horrible things distracted I think
would be a rant is a shell of his former
self I think he's very depressed now and
you feel it's right he's in over my
bottom line I think he's in over his
head with this whole thing I'm not
depressed at all
yeah you're depressed nothing you got
massive headaches we're talking about
the other day your massive headache yeah
to the point that you know you're
incapacitated that's a physical ailment
though but you'd have it last year and
like what life comes Julie I've had
these since I was born Rand ranch dress
that's what you're not a doctor I know
but I didn't office with you and and and
I can tell you that it's been a lot more
prevalent lately than it would have been
[Laughter]
[Music]
are you having this issue every every
other day when welcome a year ago it's
gotten worse in the last three months I
feel like since that jackhammer guy got
in there in the cop that they're in your
head they're their nominee yeah that's
not the case at all I can admit it
listen to what Caitlin's that's the
problem out in LA I broke some rules we
had fights about that that's it was
about my behavior not hers all right
let's go through the year in review
Brenda swing Bren told us about a
swingers of anyone - we asked them to
size up everyone at the event and this
is where Brent actually reveals he's a
seven yeah are there I mean how did the
men look on a scale of one to ten are
there tens there as well yeah there's
yeah there are where
you on that yeah I'm just curious
because I'm actually in really good
shape right now I probably about seven
to seven because I'm hey look man I had
was perfectly comfortable staying where
they're male yeah there was there was a
yeah there were guys there who are
physically impressive yeah - what big
wieners I would say not none of these
that were huge where are you everybody
was in everybody was six to eight Wow
well we did learn a lot from Brent and
Kaitlyn this year on swinging and that's
with the bottom line this show is where
we learn hey we're having a discussion
about it that's matters and there's no
part of you that wishes you had stayed
monogamous and just been with your wife
no no like it's a you're not sorry no
regret no life's an adventure and we're
having a word figuring everything out
and as we said earlier Brent kept
talking about being a swinger but three
months went by with nothing happening
and then Brent blamed his inability to
swing on Kaitlyn's new breasts here we
go I heard a rumor you and your wife are
hanging out with a black couple this
weekend potential swinging is that true
that was true that is true well we we
went out with them on Saturday night
right and well you know she can't she
still can't do anything swingin I've
ever heard of Gary she it's a medical
condition she can't do it like we went
out with a get-to-know-you she can wear
her bra but what's yeah what's how fun
is that [ __ ] a girl with a prong when
you meet up are you pricked when you're
talking are you pretending like you're
not about to [ __ ] the guy's wife is
there small talk for a while before you
get into it no that's the beauty of this
is you're not pretending that you're not
gonna [ __ ] the guy's wife you're doing
your time talking to this guy about what
she likes and what you know we're then
how isn't the deal closed if everybody
knows what they're there for
like I knew a couple
swipes teddies aren't ready yet red 22 5
e du redd
every other day it's another roadblock
and by the way medical kids had to heal
she had my injury are you [ __ ] your
wife with a broad yeah what's the
problem sure yeah absolutely
what is that enjoy your r-rated sex
after months of almost swinging Bren
told us that it finally happened and of
course brent was kind enough to share
all of the details once that's done you
Caitlyn gets on the back and the dude
puts on a condom and he starts [ __ ]
her which way generation airy to begin
with Jesus oh my god she's wrapping her
legs around him and everything yes she's
our legs spread and he's like going to
town Wow so [ __ ] steamy I love you
start crying uncontrollably I mean
you're a [ __ ] and I'm a real man
alright let's continue we're doing the
year review and brento read this
mind-blowing I guess we saw his whole
chronology we saw it all go right in
front of her eyes in the crash
there's no crashing idiot that's your
opinion
surely became doubtful of Brent's story
this past year he thought that Brent
might not be telling the truth about any
of this brent was constantly telling
Shirley he was too straight-laced here's
another example of that are you guys Jem
real hard oh yeah before the event oh
yes yes I was in there yesterday because
she would want it you know you're gonna
be nude in front of a lot of people yeah
we could work out we'll make hey whoa
nerd I mean I've already taken the
weight off is this you want to be
fine-tuned when you get high but don't
you want to be fine-tuned for your wife
not strangers Shirley shut up you square
what makes me square no it's
what a saga and then as we point out the
whole LA thing happened and that was
really mind-blowing as Ronnie
Ronnie's theory is that brent paused his
mind in LA yes he went into the bathroom
about 12 times you can't count that high
no really well I had people with me now
Ronnie's 107 right several sunglasses on
sunglasses off into this his studio had
a his studio into the green room area
back into the bathroom the guy couldn't
sit still hour at one point he was
sitting in this little studio we were
all in it and he just any sitting there
and shaking his head side to side he's
got his hand on his head he just goes
this is easily the worst failure my
radio career I gotta tell you Brent I
don't know I don't want some big
good-looking up jacked up porn star
[ __ ] my wife you see you're on a
whole different level than me mmm well I
had a good time with chicks yes you did
Brent told us he [ __ ] a girl in LA so
long that he do you take a break to
urinate hottest sex on my bed and
started getting undressed we had sex did
you eat her out no you just put it in
she said she said she wouldn't let me
eat her would she blow you she did not
blow me you put your chest no weak you
know how long were you inside if we
kissed probably 40 minutes really I had
to get up during PE change the condom
and come back this right or wait a
minute you're saying you were [ __ ]
her in the middle of [ __ ] her you had
a pee I had to get up pee and change the
condom really and then go back to it you
follow along yeah Wow Ralph has a theory
i'm brighton Caitlin you wouldn't want
to hear that well he does hang with them
so maybe you know something
yeah go ahead I mean you kind of said it
but I just think he thought this whole
swingin thing would be fun on the air
you know and it just went horribly wrong
and it's not the wrong realm what's
going wrong no it didn't
it'd be because it's just it's it's not
fun it's not funny and it's probably
something they should have explored on
their own and then kind of brought it on
the air once they got a handle on it you
know what I mean
alright so your theory is Brent
shouldn't share anything with the
audience of the show that pays me no but
I think I think Ralph's right the sense
that I think that you're not as unhappy
with the swinging as the way you're
perceived by the audience I think that's
what's weighing on you that's not what's
weighing on it at all
why is your blood pressure 190 over 106
where nothing is weighing on me I'm
having my mom a physical ailment like
I'm a natural pain no that's not you see
a therapist or a psychiatrist at all
not currently well okay wrapping up your
and review in this area there were a lot
of great drops that came from this saga
here's a montage of the best Brent drops
from last year here we go it's so
[ __ ] steamy super steamy soft
swinging can I smell your sweaty beef
I'm going to heavy metal concerts and
orgies what are you doing with your life
shut up you square there you go you
created a lot of good drops from Fred to
use and congratulations on there's one
episode that was missing about the whole
swingin thing and that's when Steve went
with them to an event right and really
described what goes on and how it smells
yeah that's one that's that's Steve's
perspective it was a little bit slanted
like Fox News print you don't know
anything I can't see yourself and you
know what it looks like to someone who's
not involved Robinson
people that aren't involved have no
perspective they don't understand people
were blowing each other next to baked
ziti they were